WITH JUAN WILLIAMS, DANA PERINO,
JESSE WATTERS, AND KENNEDY,
"THE FIVE."
♪ ♪
WELL, THE BIG ORANGE MEANIE HAS
STRUCK AGAIN.
>> TODAY I AM INSTRUCTING MY
ADMINISTRATION TO HALT FUNDING
OF THE WORLD HEALTH ORGANIZATION
WHILE THE REVIEW IS CONDUCTED TO
ASSESS THE WORLD HEALTH
ORGANIZATION’S ROLE IN SOME
SEVERE MISMANAGEMENT AND
COVERING UP THE SPREAD OF THE
CORONAVIRUS.
HAD THE W.H.O. DONE ITS JOB TO
GET MEDICAL EXPERTS INTO CHINA
TO OBJECTIVELY ASSESS THE
SITUATION UNDERGROUND AND TO
CALL OUT CHINA’S LACK OF
TRANSPARENCY, THE OUTBREAK COULD
HAVE BEEN CONTAINED AT A SOURCE
WITH VERY LITTLE DEATHS.
>> Greg: AS IF ON CUE, THE
MEDIA SPEWED.
>> THIS IS AN ATTEMPT BY THE
PRESIDENT TO STEER YOU AWAY FROM
HIS OWN ACTIONS.
>> IF YOU GO THROUGH THE
SCAPEGOATS THAT HE HAS BLAMED SO
FAR FOR THE CORONAVIRUS
PANDEMIC, THE W.H.O., MEMBERS OF
THE NEWS MEDIA, MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS.
>> WHAT YOU’RE SEEING IS A
PRESIDENT WHO DEFLECTS, DEMEANS,
AND ANNOUNCES OTHERS AS OPPOSED
TO TAKING RESPONSIBILITY.
>> IF I HAD TO SUM IT UP, I
WOULD SAY SHEER MADNESS, IT IS
STRICTLY POLITICAL.
>> WHAT HE IS ACCUSING THE
W.H.O. OF, HE DID EVEN WORSE.
>> Greg: MADNESS, OBSCENE, IT
IS A REACTION WE COME TO EXPECT
FROM THE CHILDREN IN THE ROOM,
NONE WHO CARED MUCH ABOUT THE
PANDEMIC, BECAUSE THEY WERE TOO
BUSY SMOKING THAT CRACK PIPE OF
IMPEACHMENT.
ARE YOU SURPRISED BY TRUMP’S
ACTIONS?
ARE YOU THE MEDIA THAT EVERY DAY
IS LIKE THE FIRST DAY OF THE
PRESIDENCY?
NO, YOU GET IT.
THE STRATEGY FROM DAY ONE IS
BASED ON INCENTIVE.
HE ASKS, HOW CAN WE EXPECT THE
W.H.O. TO DO BETTER IF THEY ARE
GOING TO GET MILLIONS ANYWAY.
THE W.H.O. IS LIKE EVERYTHING IN
TRUMP’S ORBIT.
IT’S GOING TO KICK THE TIRES,
THREATENED TO PULL OUT, NOTHING
IS OFF-LIMITS, ESPECIALLY IN
ORGANIZATION ORGANIZATION
NOTORIOUS FOR ABUSE.
TRUMP JUST SPANKED THE
LEADERSHIP WHO SPENT TRILLIONS
ON JETS.
IF WE ARE TAKING THE ORDER, WHY
ARE WE PAYING THE RENT?
IT’S A GOOD QUESTION, WHEN THE
MEDIA WON’T ASK.
THEY PRETEND IT IS THE END OF
THE PROCESS, WHEN IT IS JUST THE
START.
TRUMP SHAKES THE BOX TO SEE WHAT
HAPPENS NEXT.
IT’S NOT NEW, BUT IT WORKS.
THAT’S WHY YESTERDAY OBAMA SPENT
12 MINUTES SAYING NOTHING TO
DEFEND JOE, IT ALL HINGED ON
PERSONALITY.
YET TRUMP IS MEAN, BUT JOE IS
NICE.
UNLESS YOUR NAME IS TARA.
TO THE PROBLEM WITH THE DEFENSE,
THE PROOF.
DID THE STOCK MARKET CRASH WHEN
HE REAMED A COST IT EMPLOY RISE
WHEN TRUMP HAD A NICKNAME.
NO, ALL OBAMA HAS WAS THAT THE
COMPLAINT WAS AS GREAT AS HE
HAS.
YES, WE GET IT, MR. TRUMP IS
MEAN.
BUT HE IS MEAN ON OUR BEHALF.
AND THE MEDIA IMPLODES BECAUSE
HE DEMANDS CONFIDENCE FROM
PEOPLE SOAKING US FOR MILLIONS.
I GUESS IF IT WERE BIDEN,
MR. NICE GUY WOULD’VE JUST
SNIFFED TO THEIR HAIR AND CALLED
IT A DAY.
YOU KNOW, DANA, I LIKE TO OFFER
SOLUTIONS WHEN THERE ARE
PROBLEMS, AND IF YOU NOTICE WHAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP SAID, HE SAID
SUSPENDED WHILE THEY WERE REVIEW
IS BEING PERFORMED.
THIS IS BEGINNING OF THE PROCESS
WHICH WOULD BE TO FUND DIRECTLY
SO THAT WE CAN WATCH THE MONEY.
LET THE STATE DEPARTMENT WITH
THE HEALTH FUNDS.
SO WE CAN SEE WHAT IS GOING ON.
MORE TRANSPARENCY.
>> Dana: AT THE END OF THE
PROCESS WHEN IT IS FINISHED, IF
YOU HAVE UNITED STATES,
BASICALLY STILL PAYING THE LION
SHARE, BUT ALSO THEN UTILIZING
THE INFLUENCES THAT COME WITH
THAT.
WE ARE THE SUPERPOWER, AND WE
SHOULD ACT LIKE IT.
SO THEREFORE WE ARE GOING TO BE
HERE, AND THERE WILL BE A
MINDER.
AND THERE IS A UNITED STATES
PERSON THAT IS GOING TO BE
INVOLVED.
AND THERE ARE SOME GOOD THINGS
THAT THE W.H.O. DOES FOR
DEVELOPING COUNTRIES IN
PARTICULAR.
AND WHEN AN OUTBREAK LIKE A
BULLET HAPPENS.
IT’S REALLY IMPORTANT THAT
EVERYBODY IS ON THE SCENE TO
HELP TRY TO STAMP THAT DOWN.
BECAUSE MORE FAIL-SAFE IS NOT
GOOD FOR ANYBODY IN THE WORLD.
SO THERE IS THAT.
BUT WHEN IT COMES TO PROTECTING
OUR OWN HEALTH, IF WE ARE GOING
TO DO THAT, WE NEED TO GET
SOMETHING FOR IT.
I DON’T THINK THAT IT WILL ALL
GO AWAY, UNLESS THERE IS
COMPLETE AND TOTAL RESISTANCE.
IF THE W.H.O. DECIDES THAT IT
WANTS TO THUMB ITS NOSE AT
AMERICA, THEN YOU MIGHT SEE
AMERICA PULLED A FUNDING OUTPUT
AND AT THAT POINT IT WOULD
PROBABLY BE THE RIGHT THING TO
DO.
>> Greg: YOU KNOW, KENNEDY,
2018 THEY SPENT OVER
$200 MILLION ON TRAVEL EXPENSES,
AND MEANWHILE, THEY WERE HAVING
ISSUES WITH EBOLA, THEY COULD
NOT GET THE MONEY.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THIS?
>> Kennedy: I ALWAYS THINK IT
IS A GOOD IDEA TO LOOK AT THE
MASSIVE EXPENDITURES, FIGURE OUT
WHERE THE MONEY IS GOING ON
THERE TRANSPARENCY.
I DON’T HAVE A PROBLEM WITH
THAT.
IF THE W.H.O. IS SPENDING SO
MUCH MONEY ON TRANSPORTATION AND
TRAVEL, WHY DID THEY NOT GO TO
CHINA WITH A GROUP OF
INTERNATIONAL EXPERTS INCLUDING
EPIDEMIOLOGISTS FROM THE
UNITED STATES.
AND REALLY FIGURE OUT THE ORIGIN
OF THIS VIRUS.
AND I REALLY DON’T THINK NOW IS
THE TIME TO APPEASE CHINA.
I DON’T MIND IF WE TAKE
POLITICIZED NATION OUT OF THE
ENTIRE PICTURE, BUT I DON’T HAVE
A PROBLEM WITH ASKING THESE
IMPORTANT QUESTIONS.
AND WE SHOULD DO THAT WITH EVERY
GOVERNMENT BODY WHO HAS DROPPED
TO THE BALL WHETHER IT IS THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT ON THE STATE
LEVEL OR THE MASSIVE
INTERNATIONAL CONGLOMERATES,
THAT AT THIS POINT ARE DOING A
LITTLE BIT MORE HARM THAN GOOD.
>> Greg: DO YOU THINK THAT THE
W.H.O. IS THE VICTIM IN THIS?
AND WE ARE POLITICIZING THE
STORY?
AND, IT SEEMS LIKE THE MEDIA
IMMEDIATELY, WHENEVER TRUMP DOES
NOT LIKE SOMETHING, THE MEDIA
ALWAYS LIKES THAT THING HE DOES
NOT LIKE.
AND WHEN HE LIKE SOMETHING, THEY
ALWAYS TAKE THE OPPOSITION.
SO ISN’T THAT KIND OF WHAT IS
GOING ON HERE?
>> Juan: NO, LET’S TAKE THE
MEDIA OUT OF IT FOR A SECOND,
GREG.
I THINK THAT YOU CAN HAVE TWO
REALITIES.
ONE IS THAT CHINA LIES A LOT AND
LIED ABOUT THE VIRUS.
AND THE PRESIDENT IS RIGHT WHEN
HE CALLS THEM OUT.
I WISH HE WOULD DO IT MORE.
BUT SECONDLY THAT THE W.H.O.
TAKES A LOT ON FACE VALUE AND
TRIES TO WORK WITH THE
GOVERNMENTS THAT MAINTAIN OR
RETAIN THEIR SOVEREIGNTY, SO
THEY NEED THEM TO COOPERATE IN
ORDER FOR THE W.H.O. TO DO THEIR
JOB.
SO YOU HAVE THESE TWO
CONFLICTING REALITIES.
SO I THINK THE PRESIDENT IS
RIGHT TO SAY, HEY, WHY DOESN’T
CHINA STOP APPLYING?
INSTEAD OF LASHING OUT AT
W.H.O., HE SHOULD LASH OUT AT
CHINA.
BUT TO DO WHAT HE IS DOING IN
THE MIDST OF A GLOBAL PANDEMIC
IS A LITTLE BIT LIKE CUTTING OFF
YOUR NOSE DESPITE YOUR FACE.
WE NEED, WE DON’T EVEN HAVE A
REPLACEMENT.
NOBODY IN THE WORLD LEVEL IS IN
A POSITION OF THE W.H.O. TO HELP
US DEAL WITH THIS CRISIS AT THE
MOMENT.
WE CAN’T AS THE UNITED STATES
STOP IT UNLESS WE DEAL WITH THE
DEVELOPING COUNTRIES AND EVEN
WITH CHINA AGAIN, BECAUSE RIGHT
NOW I UNDERSTAND THAT THEY MAY
BE FACING A SECOND WAVE IN THAT
COUNTRY.
SO ALL OF THAT IS IMPORTANT.
AND I THINK IN TERMS OF THE
POLITICS OF IT, APART FROM THE
PRESIDENT PUTTING HIS SIGNATURE
ON STIMULUS CHECK IT, IT IS LIKE
HE IS TRYING TO DISTRACT US FROM
ALL THE CRITICS THAT SAY HE HAS
HAD SOME PROBLEMS IN TERMS OF
HIS RESPONSE.
>> Greg: WHAT DO YOU THINK,
JESSE, IS THAT THE CASE?
>> Jesse: TO JUAN’S POINT,
THEY ARE THERE TO PREVENT
PANDEMIC, AND THEY BLEW IT.
THEY ARE USELESS.
THEY ARE NOT THERE TO CURE
PANDEMIC, THEY ARE THERE TO
PREVENT TO.
AND THEY FAILED.
LET ME SHOW YOU A SNAPSHOT OF
THE W.H.O.
IT IS ROTTEN FROM THE TOP.
SO CHAIRMAN, DR. TEDROS, DO YOU
KNOW WHO HE GAVE A GOODWILL
AMBASSADOR SHIP TO?
ROBERT GO DOBBY OF ZIMBABWE.
THE BACKLASH WAS SO STRONG HE
HAD TO RESEND IT.
HE IS FROM A MARXIST
REVOLUTIONARY PARTY IN ETHIOPIA
PURITY WAS PART OF A REGIME
THERE THAT HAD REALLY BRUTAL
CRACKDOWNS, AND RIGHTS
ATROCITIES GALORE.
THE $200 MILLION THEY SPENT IN
ONE YEAR ON TRAVEL IS MORE THAN
THEY SPENT FIGHTING MALARIA,,
AND TUBERCULOSIS COMBINED.
THEY WERE BOOKING PRESIDENTIAL
SUITES WITH MARBLE BATHROOMS.
THEY WERE DOING FIRST CLASS.
THEY WERE DOING LUXURY
LIMOUSINES.
SO NOW YOU HAVE THE FLUSH FUND
RUN BY A MARXIST, BASICALLY AND
THEN AMERICAN EXPENSE ACCOUNT.
AND IT IS UNDER THE U.N.
UMBRELLA.
MUST I REMIND EVERYBODY ABOUT
THE UNITED NATIONS?
I MEAN, THIS IS LIKE FOR ARAB
DICTATORSHIPS, EUROPEAN
SOCIALISTS, THIRD WORLD WANT TO
BE’S, AND THEY ARE ALL JUST
TRYING TO TAKE DOWN AMERICA.
IT’S A PATRONAGE MILL.
AND WE PAY FOR THAT PATRONAGE
MILL.
AND OIL FOR FOOD?
THE RATE SCANDALS IN AFRICA?
THEY PREDICTED MANHATTAN WOULD
BE UNDER WATER LAST YEAR.
THE WHOLE W.H.O./U.N. SCENE IS A
BAD SCENE.
THEY HAVE A LOT OF MEETINGS AND
THEY NEVER DO ANYTHING.
WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE THAT WE GET